the printers at amazon changed the spine
so that they could fill it with their
satanic
pictures how many more books are like
this
how many more books have you put satanic
stuff through the books
what's next hey what's up my name's
samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be calling
out people on this video you know
normally i'd call it out people
you know people that bring false
allegations against me or try and attack
me and i'll call them out
um and i've been attacked by a lot of
people this year
and my mom wrote a book
okay and this this this will shock you
when you when you when you when you hear
what happened and i'm i'm
speechless i don't know how to deal with
this i don't know
how to attack the person that did it and
put it right
because this is actually amazon amazon
not just going after me but now going
after my family my mom wrote a book i
published this for my mom it's a
christian book
this is a christian book i talked about
this before on amazon i talked about
this when i spoke about how
i was getting attacked by the media and
how like joe lycett and
these clowns on channel 4 and were going
after me but
my going after my faith you know taking
the mickey out of my christian faith
taking the mickey out of my gospel music
and trying to make me feel ashamed for
just being who i am
i did a video about this and i actually
talked about my mom's book that i
published me and my team designed the
cover we designed the spine
we published this book and and the video
got a lot of hate
a little love as well but a lot of hate
now you'd expect amazon
to be neutral you'd expect the printers
at amazon to be neutral
but it's crazy that some people aren't
it's the attacks that i have had
just for being a successful property
investor and teaching people about
property and being
unashamed and not afraid to be liked or
disliked
talking openly about what i think what i
believe politically
my faith i don't know why people have
voted so bad inform me but this book
you know these are these are the
chapters it's not controversial at all
i mean these are these are the chapter
headings you know out of darkness the
bible can i trust the bible
okay christian book one life make it
count
knowing god's will opposition to our
faith standing firm
it's a nice light christian book that i
published
i designed the spine and then one copy
came
with a bigger spine okay my mom ordered
10 books
to give to some friends and she ordered
10 books and they all came normal
normal spine one came big spine
thick spine my mum's like oh that's my
mom on the back of the book my mom's
like
what's up with this book and i'm getting
attacked by everybody meanwhile
you know not just people but companies
snidey
very strange attacks and then lo and
behold my mom skips through the book
and this book is different because this
book is just a normal book
nice and light nice nice book this book
the printers at amazon changed the spine
so that they could fill it with their
satanic
pictures look at this
i i wouldn't be showing you on youtube
if amazon responded
and told me why it happened but amazon
have got nothing to say
apart from it was a mistake this is
absolutely vile my mum was horrified
i mean honestly if you want to go after
me or my business or whatever fine
but this is this is disgusting demonic
satans
jesus in in horrible
light you know pictures of schools
[Music]
inside my mom's book i published this
book
look at it goes on and on and then
and then back to the back to the normal
box they inserted that inside the book
that amazon was not a mistake the the
this was somebody somebody did this
their printer doesn't accidentally
put this in my christian book and then
make the spine bigger you know how many
times i like to keep adjusting the spine
because amazon said it needs to be the
right
amount of spine so that it fits the book
clearly it doesn't they just they just
make it bigger
and stick demonic stuff in it amazon you
should be ashamed
and amazon when i reach out to you my
mom reached out to you and said how did
it happen
what's going on all i said is it was a
mistake we can
refund the book how many more books are
like this
how many more books have you put satanic
stuff through the box
what's next amazon amazon have made so
much money over the last six months
jeff bezos has made more over the
pandemic than um
the the the warren buffett's made in his
entire life
they're a big company and to be doing
this sort of stuff
you know i mean getting getting hate and
horrible messages and stuff off of
trolls online is one thing
you know but this is just ridiculous and
i'm tired of it
i'm tired of it what the heck is going
on but let me tell you this
amazon or whoever's did this the
printers that work for amazon
who should be fired let me tell you
something you know if this was an attack
on me
or if you're trying to get to me or get
to my family or whatever which people do
i'm just going to say i'm not stopping
i'm going to continue
making money in property i'm going to
continue talking about it i'm going to
continue helping people become
financially free every single week i'm
going to continue not caring about
whether i'm liked or disliked i'm going
to continue talking about what i believe
about the government
politically i'm going to continue being
an unashamed christian
i don't care this is this is pathetic
it's sick it's wrong it's disgusting and
i would expect better from amazon and
amazon you had your chance to respond
and put this right but you didn't
and and i am speechless i don't know
what to say
get off my back like serious i'm just a
legitimate businessman doing my thing
helping people no issues no problems
that's just wrong so anyway sorry to
lower the tone on saturday night
i was just so shocked i felt like i had
to do a video tomorrow i'm doing a video
q a sunday when i'm teaching property
answering your property investment
questions
you're gonna keep getting successful i'm
going to keep enjoying it
and this horrible satanic attacks
i'm getting this from all angles all
places hard
but i'm going to keep doing what i'm
doing